dans une société qui a besoin de
proximité qui a perdu la confiance elle
a perdu la confiance parce que nous
avons une crise des résultats depuis des
années et des années
la décentralisation c'est quoi c'est
prendre des décisions plus près et ont
rejoint le gaullisme social et la
proximité c'est là où il faut mutualiser
le faire ensemble est confiée à l'état
ses grandes missions régaliennes mais
arrêtez la verticalité du pouvoir la
verticalité nous a conduit à la crise
des gilet jaune à une certaine
conception aussi de la proche des
retraites l'absence de dialogue social
territorial aulas typiquement une
réalité et ce matin par la situation il
ya le feu chez les policiers
la justice est en crise le ministère du
travail a perdu la clé du dialogue
social
on n'arrive pas à faire un passer un
message sur l'environnement est un conte
en amérique comme la dette je ne parle
même pas des déficits c'est quand même
trente six mois qui ne sont guère
brillants depuis l'arrivée à la
présidence de la république d'emmanuel
macro et là alors si vous avez eu le
bonheur absolu mais je pars nature par
nature nous allons observer les travaux
pratiques histoire si vous êtes très
traitement les travaux pratiques
c'est savez le remaniement c'est pas une
politique qui compte c'est la politique
qui aura derrière le remaniement ça fait
un buzz ça dure une semaine une
politique c'est ce qu'on doit conduire
dans les 18 mois qui viennent et c'est
là dessus qu'on jugera
c'est aussi la méthode sénatoriales on
ne fait jamais à priori jamais non
jamais non par dogmatisme jamais oui par
discipline crise économique chômage
situation des jeunes les territoires
quelle réponse on apporte
le secteur de la santé est ce que c'est
simplement une révision indispensable
des grilles salariales ou est ce que on
a une vraie réorganisation du système de
santé
est-ce qu'on sort du seul hospital aux
centristes
et puis informe du chômage qu'est ce
qu'on fait de la réforme en cours
réforme des retraites
voilà des sujets qui sont sur le devant
le sujet de la dépendance
tout cela c'est ce qu'on appelle les
travaux pratiques et c'est là dessus que
d'ailleurs au sénat nous serons
attentifs
toujours dans une vision positive mais
nous serons aussi exigeant sur ces
points-là contribuer à la sortie de
crise préparé le projet c'est ce que
vont faire les républicains d'ici cet
automne ensuite choisir une candidate ou
un candidat ce sera ce que nous aurons à
faire dans les mois qui viennent et
s'inscrire dans le grand débat dans la
vème république et l'élection
présidentielle on a presque oublié voyez
dix jours après on a presque oublié
pardonnez moi la grande défaite de la
république en marche aux élections
municipales cette réalité c'est que la
république en marche n'est pas un parti
ancré dans le territoire
premier parti sur le territoire c'est la
famille des républicains avec ses alliés
notamment de la droite et du centre